Gonna Play a clip and guys in the chat I
will want you to weigh in on this also
women in the chat I'd like you to weigh
in on this are they right do are they on
the money with what they think what they
perceive
men want let's listen
that's my answer and then what do you
think men are looking for in women
I think it all comes down to just like
looking for that connection so
I don't know I've like read and heard
things that like men want to feel wanted
or needed
um
nurtured in a way like
don't know I feel like most men are just
like big babies like it's not as deep as
we think it is so they just want to feel
like that connection with a woman and
feel cared for but maybe they get that
feeling in different ways than women get
from Men
a big one would be confidence because a
lot of women now our days are insecure
so when they get in a relationship and a
guy even says hi to another female they
freak out or I know a lot of females
stalk their significant other social
medias
um but you know if you're confident in
your woman you should know what you
bring to the table what you offer and if
he's not appreciating that then he's not
the one for you so
um I think confidence is big I think
just respect is another huge one because
a lot of girls nowadays and clubs man
it's crazy they're crazy so
um a woman with you know confidence good
respect good morals good upbringing
um I think those things are very
important I would hope that's what men
are looking for men are looking for just
it's different for every guy but I would
hope that they're just looking for you
know what women are looking for like
someone to hang out with someone to get
to know someone to experience things
with
um
and just like grow a relationship with
for guys I think that they want someone
they can hang out with
um obviously sex usually for men is a
huge thing
being chill I think guys don't like
confrontation and fights obviously I
don't either I know some people do but
um being easy going I don't think guys
like pressure also from girls like I
think guys really want to be the one
kind of
leading the whole relationship so
if a girl's giving too much they get
scared off at first
um
so yeah I think that's a big one as well
I think eagerness kind of turns guys off
I feel like men are really hard on women
these days just because
we are expected to be all these things
and we're all these different hats we're
um expected to be these boss ladies but
also feminine also really good in the
kitchen I really got in the bed so there
are a lot of expectations on women from
men to like fulfill the role of the
wifey material uh it depends what kind
of man but I think
the person who I would look for
probably wants a woman that has her own
success
and
I think a lot of men want a woman who
takes care of herself whether that's
physically or mentally or really both
and
feels like they have a purpose and isn't
too dependent
on
a man kind of the same thing I mean
it's different back in the 50s it was
you stay at home you take care of the
kids and that's what you do and now they
want independent hard-working women so I
think a lot of guys just want a Down to
Earth girl that
doesn't really play games is not out
there talking to 10 15 20 different guys
and knows what she's looking for and
doesn't have to go to the bars every
single weekend just to feel better
all right guys it is okay so
some some right some wrong right some of
these are fascinating though and Tyler
you know you're going to weigh in on
this and just Tyler's like
I see that face this comment the top
comment the top 20 2500 likes says a
plus for Courtney once again exposing
how women literally have zero clue as to
what is actually going on well I think
that's true in many respects
um it's fascinating so some of the
comments that stuck out for me
first of all the woman who just said she
wanted somebody a guy who had to make
four hundred thousand dollars and take
care of her the kids the home the pair
the her parents the Elder everybody you
know Sam and Joe went down the street
she says men are hard on women
honey
self-reflect a little bit okay
um she also says that guys want a boss
lady guys don't want a boss lady they're
not that that is why women want to be a
boss lady for other women oftentimes and
sometimes for themselves they want to
feel like a boss you know I sometimes
women say I feel like a boss you know
it's like get your confidence pumping
guys they're they're not no no guys out
there like I want a boss lady no they're
not saying that doll they don't care
about that at all also just a reality
uh the girl who says that you know oh I
think guys want a woman who has her own
success I don't think that's the case
all the time either I don't think they
need you to have this like on their
their short list is not like woman must
have her own Financial and Professional
success I don't think that's on most
guys shortlist I don't
um isn't too dependent I also think
that's wrong I think that men are really
really comfortable
a lot of times with you leaning on them
and with them being the leader of the
house and for them to take the the big
financial responsibility as long as in
turn they're getting something that they
that they want out of that dynamic
independent hard-working women
to an extent to an extent so let me tell
you what's on my list for what I think
you tell me guys in the chat Tyler you
can weigh into tell me if you think I
I get it right first of all I think guys
want someone they're attracted to they
got to be tracked you don't have to be
you know Heidi Klum but you someone that
they are physically attracted to
intimacy is very sex is important to
guys okay it's a very very important
they have to wanna you know jumpy bones
they like that okay traction
I think they want someone in this word
by the way gets under certain female
skin a lot
Pleasant
okay it is it's prickly for women
sometimes because what happens is when
women hear the word Pleasant they think
oh you just want a trophy wife you just
want me to sit and smile all the time
that's not really what they mean by it I
think what they mean by it is
oftentimes they are willing to go out
there and work their butts off to make
you know that two hundred thousand
dollars a year to bring home and take
care of the family and do all those
things but when they do get home they
want to be able to talk to someone who's
out in a bad mood who's not cranky who
by the way this gets into the problem
with two working people we can talk
about that in a second but I think they
want someone who's generally easy going
and nice to be around you know Pleasant
like not drama they don't want like all
the like guys literally like a flame
starts inside their body when you start
bringing up stuff they did 15 years ago
they're like didn't we have this
conversation like come on oh but you did
this and do you remember that time we
went to your sister's house do you
remember what you said to me outside I
do and she verbatim repeats what you
said 15 years ago and you're like good
God I'm Gonna Be in My Grave hearing
these words
they don't want to deal at all it's like
a lot of like they just can't they don't
like competition the girl who said that
is right they don't it's just too much
at some point
I think they want less stress less drama
they want someone who's feminine a lot
of times
and by that means I think they like well
groomed they don't want you to have like
hands look like man hands oh I feel so
naked without my rings I had this kind
by the way everyone yes I am still
married I love my husband's pieces I'm
getting my rings adjusted I feel naked I
feel like I'm naked here anyway
um I think they want someone who has you
know feet that look like a woman's feet
pedicure you know they want you to take
care of yourself exercise care about
your health care about your Wellness
they like those little things that you
do that make you different in fact you
put the lotion on and you have the soft
skin grooming grooming that women do I
think is important to men
they don't want you to be headaches they
don't want you to be the type of woman
who goes out and gets drunk all the time
and goes out with your friends and you
like uh has a crew of girlfriends that
are troublemakers like they have to sit
at home and worry like what's going on
over there where are they going to wind
up oh is that friend gonna try to they
don't need all that it's just drama
headache aggravation if you want to
watch the full episode you're going to
click right here and if you want to ask
me a question one on one you want to do
a one-on-one face time with a group of
your friends whatever you want you need
to download manect right now click right
here and let's get talking
foreign
[Music]